[Alkış]
çalışmayı sevmek diye girmek istiyorum
konuya çok zor bir konu
pazartesi sendromu diye bir kelimenin
olduğu bir dünyada yaşıyoruz çalışmayı
sevmek
Steve Jobs demiş ki;
du What you love love you do Yani tam
Türkçeye çevirince sevdiğiniz işi yapın
yaptığınız işi sevin
şimdi bu ikisi birbirine çok zıt iki
cümle ve ikisini birden öneriyor
bunun birbirine zıt olduğunu ise çoğu
kez fark edemiyoruz
sevdiğimiz işi yapmakla yaptığımız işi
sevmeyi aynı şeyi zanneden pek çok kişi
olabiliyor Çünkü biz bizi kendi halimize
bırakırlarsa gerçekten sevdiğimiz şeyi
biliyoruz Ve onun peşinden gitmek
istiyoruz
çok azımız
ya bir dakika ben
bu şeyi karşıma gelen bu işi
sevmeye çalışacağım sevmeyi öğrenmeye
çalışacağım peşinde değiliz
ve
buradan galiba ben kendi adıma İşte bu
sorgulamayı yapmamaktan dolayı pek çok
şey kaybediyor olduğumuzu düşünüyorum
yani
sevdiğimiz şeyi yapmaya çalışırken
karşımıza gelen şeyleri sağa sola iterek
Hayır bu değil bu hiç değil diyerek
devamlı o şeylere maruz kalmak yani o
işin işe maruz kalmak ve onunla idare
etmeye çalışmak
bir problem gibi geliyor bize Ben şimdi
açıkçası şöyle bir soru sormak istiyorum
hani Buraya kendi inşa ettiği arabaya
binip gelen var mı ya da oturduğu evi
Kendisi bayağı tuğlası ile sıvasıyla
inşa edip içinde yaşayan var mı ya da ne
bileyim üstüne kıyafetlerinizi düşünün
Pamuklu olduklarını düşünün yani
pamuğunu siz ekmişsiniz sonra oradan
biçmişsiniz Oradan iplik yapmışsınız
dikmişsiniz sonra giyip gelmişsiniz
aranızda böyle birisi var mı Bunu niye
soruyorum Çünkü gerçekten medeniyet
hepimiz aynı durumdayız
kendi yapmadığımız şeylerle yaşıyoruz
oturduğumuz sandalyeleri Siz yapmadınız
hayatınızda etrafınızda kullandığınız
tükettiğiniz şeyleri Sizler yapmadınız
Bu arada Sizler yapmadınız derken hani
siz ne kadar tembel insanlarsınız
anlamında söylemiyorum Elon musk'da
kullandığı şeyleri kendisi yapmıyor
büyük oranda yani ve
bunu sorgulamamız gerekiyor medeniyet
denen şey böyle muhteşem bir şey
verebiliyor Eskiden ormandaki yaşamdan
çok farklı bir şey Eskiden Herkes kendi
başını çaresine bakıyordu kendi
avladığını ancak tüketebiliyordu kendi
yapabildiği evin içinde yaşayabiliyordu
şimdi nasıl çalıştığını anlamadığımız
nereden geldiğini bilmediğimiz
inanılmaz şeyler bizim elimize medeniyet
tarafından sunuluyor Yani kendi
başımızın çaresine bakmak artık bizim
elimizden çıktı medeniyetin elinde
medeniyet bize şunu söylüyor diyor ki;
ya sen kendini düşünme Ben seni
hallediyorum Senin kendi isteklerin var
ya Kendi problemlerin var ya çözmek
istediğin onları Ben çözerim Senin kendi
başına çözemeyeceğin kadar iyi çözerim
diyor kendine bir araba yapmaya çalışma
Ben sana daha iyi senin kendine
Yapabileceğin arabadan daha iyisini
yaparım ya da bir daha mesela ısıtacağım
teknolojisi diye bir şey ne bileyim ya
da ABS teknolojisi ya da termostatlar ya
da işte uçağın kanatsa kaldırma kuvveti
Yani o kadar çok şeyin
anlamadığımız bilmediğimiz şeyi bize
çözüyor ki ve medeniyet şunu istiyor
sadece bizden
bütün bu problemlerini Ben çözerken Ya
sen kendi bir sürü problemine
odaklanacağına
Sen bir sürü kişinin tek bir problemine
odaklan
bir sürü kişinin tek bir problemine
odaklan İşte o zaman alışveriş çözülüyor
Yani aslında şunu diye medeniyet bize
işe gitmek bizle alakalı bir şey değil
iş bizim hayallerimizin peşinden
koştuğumuz yer değil iş
başkalarını hayallerine ulaştırmak için
başkalarının problemlerini çözmek için
gittiğimiz yer işin kapısından girerken
gerçekten hayalleri kapıda bırakmak
gerekiyor
ve gerçekten hizmetkarlık moduna girmek
gerekiyor çünkü gerçekten işit işten
çıktıktan sonra zaten bütün insanlar
bize zaten diye benden ne dilerse
diyorlar restorana gidiyorsun
oturuyorsun menü geliyor gösteriyorsun
bunu istiyorum diyorsun ve mutfakta
birileri uğraşıyor senin için medeniyet
böyle bir şey yani kendi çalıştığınız
şirket haricindeki dünyadaki bütün
şirketlerin sahibisiniz Aslında
patronusunuz istediğiniz gibi o egosal
ihtiyaçlarınızı işten çıktıktan sonra
yaşayabiliyorsunuz ama medeniyet diyor
ki
bunun tadını yaşamak için Ya bunun
tadını çıkartmak için lütfen işinizde
artık kendi hayalinizin peşinden koşmayı
bırakın iş sizle ilgili değil geri
kalanlarla ilgili bir şey
ve çalışmayı O yüzden sevmek denen şey
bu anlamda çok adil bir şey yani
hayatımızın tamamında kendi
mutluluğumuzu çözmeye çalışırken
medeniyet diyor ki 8 saat Lütfen kendi
mutluluğunu çözmeye başkaları
mutluluğunu çözmeye birdenbire Nihayet
bir denge geliyor ve denge geldiği yerde
zaten sürdürülebilirlik gelir işte
oradan anlamamız lazım sadece
Sürdürülebilir şeyler sürdürülebilirler
Adı üstünde o yüzden biz onlardan başka
hiçbir şekilde ilerleyemeyeceğimiz yol
alamayacağımız anlamamız lazım O yüzden
çalışmakla alakalı bu pazarlığı Yani
evet istediğimiz kadar İçimizden gelmese
de artık yapmayı bırakmak Pazartesi
sendromunu bırakmak ve zaten artık işi
sevmesek bile sonuçlarını sevmeyi
öğrenmek yani
müşterimizin mutluluğundan mutlu olmayı
öğrenmek Eğer bunu yapabilirsek
birdenbire Bütün işler zaten doğru
yapıldığında
müşterisini mutlu eder Ve siz de
müşterinin mutluluğundan mutlu
olabilirsiniz birdenbire Bütün işler
eşit derecede ilginç eşit derecede
tatmin edici hale gelir iş ne olursa
olsun sevimli hale gelir işten sonra da
zaten Hayat medeniyet size bütün
problemlerinizi çözmeye Sizi bütün
hayallerinizi gerçekleştirmek için canla
başla sizin için çalışıyor olacak
fakat
bu idraka gelsek dahi
ne yazık ki ben biraz Gelecekle alakalı
pesimistim teknolojinin
işsizler bütün işleri birer birer
elimizden alması bizleri değersiz
kılması gibi bir problem bence çok hızlı
geliyor
Yapay Zeka makine öğrenmesi algoritmalar
gibi kavramlar çok daha hızlı bir
şekilde hayatımızdalar ve 2017 senesinde
muazzam bir kırılma oldu
Google'ın da şimdi sahibi oldu bir Yapay
Zeka şirketi
çok daha az kapasitesi olmasına rağmen
işlem gücü bakımından
sadece 4 saat içerisinde süper insan
seviyesinde
satranç oynamaya başladığı ve diğer
yapay zekaları da ki kendisinden kat kat
daha hızlı işlem yapabilen diğer yapay
zekaları yenmeye başladı
ve çok enteresan bir kırılma olmakta şu
anda Yani gerçekten
bilgisayarlar idraka geliyorlar Ve
bizlerin
çözebildiklerini Bizler kadar iyi
bizlerden daha iyi çözmeye gerçekten
başlıyorlar O yüzden işimizi Sevsek bile
yakın bir gelecekte Yakın derken ben
kendi adıma Hani 10 yıl üstüne bir 10
yıl daha koyarsak 20 yıllık zaman
içerisinde Yani pek çoklarınızın daha
hala iş üretebildiği yaşlarda pek
çoktanınızın hala genç olabildiği
yaşlarda
yani her zaman sizin yaptığınız işi
sizden daha iyi ve hızlı yapan bir
makine ile yazılımla algoritmayla
kapışıyor olacağınız gibi bir durum var
gelecekte kendi adıma ve bununla alakalı
çok projeksiyonlarda var bu şekilde o
yüzden de burada
işimizi Sevsek bile ve ben anladım
medeniyet oyununu Ya ben yani seviyorum
Müşteri memnuniyetidir deyip işinize
gitseniz bile bir iş bulmama ihtimali
var
ve Burada şu kavram ortaya çıkıyor
Kapitalizm kelimesi Aslında çok böyle
alıştığımız bir kelime
kimilerinde iyi duygular kimlerin kötü
duygular yaratıyordur ama bu konu
duygusal bir konudan bahsetmeyeceğim
Kapitalizm derken ben
duygusuz bir şekilde bir mühendisin
bakış açısıyla kapitalizmi nasıl görmek
gerekiyor Onu izah etmeye çalışacağım
Kapitalizm kapitalden gelir Kapital
sermayedir tam Türkçesi
sermayecilik gibi bir şey Ve bu çok
önemli bir şey sermaye ama pek çoklarına
sorarsak sermaye nedir diye çoğu onun
para olduğunu sermaye paradır gibi çok
genel bir tanımda hayatını
konumlandırmış bu çok büyük bir eksiklik
sermaye Aslında para değildir sermaye
değer üreten Değerdir değer üreten değer
yani şöyle bir şey birisine ihtiyacını
çözer
ama sonra kendisi
azalmaz erimez Yok olmaz
ve o yüzden bir daha bir daha tekrar
tekrar çözebilir Yani bir nevi Altın
yumurtlayan tavuk gibi bir şey düşünün
her bir problemi çözdüğünde bunun bir
değeri olduğu için bir değer kazanır ama
sonra tekrar tekrar devam edebilir
yoluna ve işte günümüzde sermaye
dediğimiz şey her türlü makine teknoloji
yazılım yani bizleri işsiz bırakacak
olan şeyler
sermayedir
ve bu da bir tesadüf değildir Çünkü
içinde olduğumuz sistem Kapitalizm yani
sermayecilik üzerine bir sistemde
olduğumuz için sermaye yani cansız
sermaye coşmaktadır on yıllardan beri
coşmaktadır ve onunla para kazanmak
Aslında Bu sistemin Özünde vardır
Kimileri işte pasif gelir falan da
diyebilir ve bu pasif gelir konusu yani
emeğimizle çalışıp para kazanmak değil
de
sahip olduğumuz teknolojilerin
aracılığıyla onları onların üzerinden
para kazanmak zaten bildiğiniz bir şey
pek çoğu evi var kiraya veriyor işte Al
sana pasif gelir Yani al sana sermaye
üzerinden para kazanmak geçmişte böyle
yapanlar vardı Kimisi işte şirket hisse
senedi alır
orada da ne yapmış oluyor şirketi hisse
senedinde o şirketin İçindeki bütün
taşınmazları Satın almış oluyor masasız
sandalyesi patenti bilgisayarları
yazılımları makineleri bütün bunları
satın alıyor ve bütün bu robotların
kendisi için çalışmasını sağlıyor gibi
bir şey oluyor Neyse bunlar Eskiden
opsiyonel bir şeydi ama
Teknoloji artık yani rahatlıkla
kapışabildiğimiz bir şeydi eskiden ama
şimdi o kapı kapanmak üzere olduğu için
gelecekte
hararinin kitabını okuyanlar da bunu
biliyorlardır 21 yüzyıl için 21 ders
kitabında da buna önemli bir kısım
ayırıyor yakın gelecekte gerçekten
hiçbir işe yaramayan insanlar diye bir
yeni bir grup oluşacağı öngörülüyor
ve gerçekten de bu kişiler halen para
kazanabilmek istiyorlarsa ya da toplum
içerisinde değer üreten ve değer tüketen
durumda kalabilmek istiyorlarsa tek bir
çareleri kalacak O da sermayeyi tutunmak
Yani bugün çalıştığımızla kazandığımızla
Belki de geçinmek değil de onu gerçekten
çok ciddi bir şekilde tutumlu kullanıp
bir şekilde biriktirip yani ayakkabı
almak tatile gitmek gibi değil Bize
ayakkabıyı alacak olan o sermayeyi satın
almak Dolayısıyla Onun bize devamlı
ücretsiz şekilde ayakkabı alması ya da
tatile gitmek değil Bize devamlı tatile
götürecek olan o sermayeyi satın almakla
alakalı bir yol bulmak gerekiyor Bu
Tabii dile kolay ve Bunu sağlayan bir
sistem içerisinde yaşamıyoruz tam
tersine kimseye birikim yapmaması
ve ileride hiçbir değeri kalmayacak olan
kendi vücutlarıyla
hayatlarını kazanmaya devam etmelerinin
çok mantıklı olduğu anlatılıyor Ama
dediğim gibi bu vücut sermayelerimiz
gitgide değersizleşirken bizlerin
buradan kazandıklarımızı
cansızlara yatırmamız ve onların
üzerinden topluma Emek borcumuzu topluma
hizmet borcumuzu onlar aracılığıyla
ödemek gibi bir şey git gide mecburiyete
doğru dönüşüyor Ben kendi adıma Tabi
bunu fark edince ne yaptık son kısımda
bundan bahsetmek istiyorum
şirketimiz de bir yeni bir şey denedik
Aslında konuyu Sabahtan beri oraya
getirmeye çalışıyorum
bizim şirketimiz mühendislerin
tasarımcıların yazılımcıların
geliştiricilerin çalıştığı teknolojiler
geliştirdikleri ürünler tasarladıkları
bir şirket ve Burada en azından işte
ortaya koyduğumuz her türlü Eser bizzat
sermaye Yani bir arkadaşımız bir tasarım
yaptığında o tasarım artık kendi başına
insanların işini çözen ama o sırada
kendisi azalmayan yok olmayan tam
anlamıyla sermayenin tanımına uygun bir
şey oluyor Ve bunu yapan tasarımcı
arkadaşımız klasik şirketlerde Normalde
tasarımı şirketine verir ardından
maaşını alır ve hayat güzelce devam eder
ama işte yakın gelecekte sermayeye
tutunamayan insanların bir sıkıntıya
yaşayacağı öngörüsüyle Biz şuna karar
verdik
arkadaşlarımız geliştirdikleri bu
tasarımları fikirleri sistemleri şirkete
satmasınlar maaş karşılığında
Biz onları Eğer katabildikleri şey
gerçekten değerli olduğunu
tescilleyebilirsek ve bize gerçekten
durmadan para kazandırabileceğini hep
beraber ispat edebilirsek artık biz onu
o kişiye ait bırakalım ve şirket olarak
ona devamlı kira ödeyelim
Yani bu sermayeniz sahibi Onu bizzat
geliştiren mühendis olmaya devam etsin
En azından Çünkü mühendislerden
yazılımcılardan tasarımcılardan
geliştiricilerden başlayabiliriz Çünkü
onlar En azından bizzat sermayeyi
tasarlayanlar oluşturanlar arasındalar
En azından bir yerlerden para biriktirip
sermaye satın almak yerine o onu yerine
daha da direkt olarak kendi
oluşturduklarını bari onlarda bırakarak
da çok güçlü bir başlangıç yapabiliriz
Ve dediğim gibi bunu sağlamaya çalışan
bir model başlattık ve
şu anda şirketimizdeki herkes O yüzden
ne ile uğraşıyor ben bu şirkete kalıcı
neler katabilirim Ben gittikten sonra da
devam edebilen benim dışımda hala değer
üretebilen neler oluşturabilirim hangi
sistemleri kurabilirim hangi yazılımları
geliştirebilirim
ve Bu çok daha farklı bir işe bakış
başlattı ve
endüstri 4.0 diye bir laf vardır Çok
sıkıcı bir laf Aslında Özünde şudur
insan olmadan değer üretmeye
devam etmek geceleri ışıkları kapalı
Fabrikalar ama halen üretim yapmaya
devam ediyorlar Çünkü her şey otomasyona
bağlanmış
bu korkunç gibi geliyor peki insanlar ne
yapacaklar falan gibi ama bütün o
makinelerin sahipleri insanlar olduktan
sonra ve hem de o makinanın sahipleri o
makineleri geliştiren insanlar olduktan
sonra ve bütün o fabrikayı tek bir kişi
sahip olmayıp da o fabrikanın tamamına
onlarca yüzlerce binlerce mühendis sahip
olduktan sonra bu o kadar da karanlık
bir Gelecek hayali değil bütün herkesin
özgürleşmesi belli bir yıl çalıştıktan
sonra kendilerine emekliye ayırmaları ve
topluma hizmet borçlarını
dünya üzerine ödemeleri aslında
bir tarafından bakacak olursanız muazzam
bir Ütopya harika bir hayalin
gerçekleşmesi O yüzden biz böyle
olduğunu düşünerek buna inanarak Bu
şekilde bir yapı geliştirmeye çalıştık
hayatın para kazanmanın Ben ne yapıyorum
nereye kadar böyle bir şey olacak
gelecekte teknolojiyi karşı nasıl
kendimizi savunacağız gibi pek çok
hepimizin Aklındaki soruya da hani kendi
adımız ve Bizim şirketteki
arkadaşlarınla bir cevap olduğunu
düşündüğüm için çok heyecanla ve
önemseyerek sizlerle paylaşmak istedim
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]